slope is defined as your change in the
vertical direction and i could re use
the greek letter delta this little
triangle here is the greek letter delta
it means change in
change in the vertical direction
divided by change in the horizontal
direction that is the definition of
slope or the standard definition for
slope and it's a reasonable way for
measuring how steep something is so for
example if we're looking at the x y
plane here our change in the vertical
direction is going to be a change in the
y variable divided by change in
horizontal direction is going to be a
change in the x variable and so let's
see why that is a good definition for
slope
well i could draw something with a slope
of 1 a slope of one might look something
like
let me i could start it over here
and let me get my line tool out so slope
of one
as x increases by one y increases by one
so slope of one is going to look like
is going to look like this
is going to look like
it's going to look like this notice as i
have a change in x however much my
change in x is so for example here my
change in x is plus 2 is positive 2 i'm
going to have the same change in y
i'm my change in y is going to be plus
2. so my change in y divided by change
in x is 2 divided by 2 is 1. so for this
line i have a slope
slope is equal to 1.
but what would a slope of 2 look like
well a slope of 2 should be steeper and
we could draw that a slope of 2 i could
start at that same point actually why
don't i start at the same point and
we'll see but you don't have to actually
start at a different point so if i start
over let's say here a slope of 2 would
look like
a slope of 2
would look like for every 1 that i
increase in the x direction i'm going to
increase 2 in the y direction
so it's going to look like
it is going to look like
that
this line right over here you see it if
my change in x is 1
change in x is equal to one my change in
y
my change in y
my change in y is two so change in y
over change in x is going to be two over
one the slope here is two
and now hopefully you're appreciating
why this definition of slope is a good
one the higher the slope the steeper it
is the faster it increases the faster
our we increase in the vertical
direction as we increase in the
horizontal direction
now what would a negative slope be so
let's just think about what a line with
a negative slope would mean
well a negative slope would mean that
well we could take an example if we have
a if we have our change in y over change
in x
was say let's say it was equal to
a negative one
that means that if we have a change in x
of one
then in order to get negative one here
that means that our change in y
would have to be equal to negative one
so aligned with a negative slope a
negative one slope would look like let
me see if i can draw it
it would look like
a negative one slope
would look like
would look like this
notice as x increases as x increases
by a certain amount
so our delta x here is 1
y decreases by that same amount instead
of increasing so now this is what we
consider a downward sloping
line so change in y is equal to negative
one so our change in y over change in x
change in y over change in x is equal to
negative one over one which is equal to
negative one so the slope of this line
is negative one now if you had a slope
with negative 2 it would decrease even
faster so a line with a slope of
negative 2 it could look something like
this
let me draw it
so
as x increases by 1 y would decrease by
2 as x increases by one y would decrease
by two so it would look something like
let me see if i can it would look
like
it would look like
that
notice as our x increases by a certain
amount
our y decreases decreases by twice as
much so this right over here has a slope
this has a slope
of
negative 2. so hopefully this gives you
a little bit more intuition for what
slope represents and how the the number
that we used to represent slope how you
can use that to visualize how steep a
line is a very high positive slope as x
increases it's going to y is going to
increase fairly dramatically if you have
a negative slope you're actually going
to go
from you're actually going to go as x
increases your y is actually going to
decrease and then the higher slope the
steeper in in
the the the more you increase as x
increases and the more negative the
slope the more you decrease as x
increases